the family of a former University of
Alabama student who was allegedly raped
and then later took her own life has
filed a wrongful death lawsuit
Megan Ron Deniz parents say her rape
claims were mishandled by sheriff's
investigators and school officials they
also believe her alleged attacker
escaped prosecution because of his
prominent and wealthy family
mark Strassmann is on the campus in
Tuscaloosa Alabama with more on this
story mark good morning good morning a
mega run DS parent says she blossomed
into an outgoing honors student during
her first two years in this campus but
all that changed in July of 2015 after
she reported being raped and felt
betrayed by people she thought were
supposed to help her Megan Ron Dean II
spoke to a sheriff's investigator hours
after escaping her alleged rapist house
she thought that she was being treated
like a suspect you have robbed her
myself because when she fled Ron Dini
says she found and accidentally fired
her alleged attackers gun and also took
$3 from his wallet to pay for cab fare
it was then that we started to learn
that this wasn't going like a normal
investigation she's like we asked mother
I think it's my fault Megan's mother
Cindy drove from Texas to Alabama to
comfort her daughter
investigators also questioned then 34
year-old Terry Bunn jr. the man run Dini
said raped her
I appreciate your professionalism I
appreciate a grand jury later declined
to indict Bunn whose family owns a large
construction company in town when he was
appointed to a State Conservation Board
the local paper wrote a glowing profile
his families were very well connected
when Ron Dini sought counseling from the
University her first therapist had to
withdraw
because she personally knew bun a
federal lawsuit filed by the Ronde knees
on Monday accuses bun members of the
Sheriff's Department and two university
officials of causing Meghan extreme
depression anxiety PTSD and feelings of
worthlessness and hopelessness which
directly led to Meghan's loss of life we
would get phone calls where she would be
afraid she's like mom there's a car
outside and it keeps circling she just
she didn't feel safe
Ron Dean II committed suicide in
February of last year
shortly after transferring to a college
in Texas the University of Alabama told
CBS this morning its employees handled
their responsibilities with care at all
times keeping Meghan's well-being as
their absolute highest priority Bunz
attorney said the allegations against my
client as set forth in this baseless
lawsuit are simply false no sexual
assault occurred this case may have a
long road to travel CBS News legal
analyst Ricky Clemens says the sheriff
and his deputy are immune to the lawsuit
under state law but university officials
could be vulnerable assuming that you
could prove causation of their actions
to the ultimate suicide many many months
later the Sheriff's Office wouldn't
comment we reached out to bun and didn't
hear back Megan would have graduated
this year her parents say any money they
win through this lawsuit will be donated
to groups that help rape victims Jeff
Clark thank you very much
Ricky makes an interesting point that he
said that this case may have a long road
yeah a lot of points of view there but
the bottom line is that Ron Dinis lost a
beautiful daughter and nothing is gonna
make that better no nothing nothing for
that your honor I'm sorry to hear that